Er. Hat es tatsächlich geschafft allen masc die batterie fahren in australien in weniger als 100 tagen gebaut wir hatten ja hier schon, mal
Vermutet dass die batterie viel früher starten aber die power pack celebration, im september war wohl nur eine kleine feier jetzt aber ist es
So weit wie weit genau und warum machst jetzt 50 millionen dollar spart jetzt sind es zurzeit fiction herzlich willkommen
Es ist ein absolut sensationelles projekt die größte batterie farben der welt, am 10 märz hat der masken twittert dass tesla die
energieprobleme des bundesstaats
Südaustralien in 100 tagen lösen wolle und darauf würde er wetten sind aus reihen leidet darunter dass immer mehr kohlekraftwerke
Abgeschaltet wurden und windparks und gaskraftwerke jetzt nicht in der lage sind ausreichend strom zu produzieren um die
Belastungsspitzen abzufangen immer wieder kommt es dort zu stromausfällen ein systembedingt das problem
regenerativer energien egal ob solarzellen oder windkraftwerke der strom steht nicht dauerhaft zur verfügung allen masc lösung für dieses problem ein
Netzwerk aus batterien
er will die
energieversorgung revolutionieren
dazu gehören solar
dachziegel und die power wort batterien und batterie farben seine vision ein netzwerk mit
batterien in wohnungen und häusern und batterie farben und die stromerzeugung aus der sonne mit tesla seiner ziegen und für die tesla elektroautos
wird so preiswert und umweltfreundlich strom erzeugt und erscheint dazu tatsächlich relativ
Problemlos in der lage zu sein mit der fertigung des tester modells drei hat er ja riesige problem
er kann die produktion einfach nicht richtig starten noch wird das model 3
Quasi von hand in extrem niedrigen stückzahlen gefertigt schon wird es hat deshalb ein frühes ende vorausgesagt aber
Maske hält dagegen gerade hat er den tesla strom
Lkw vorgestellt und einen supersportwagen der 400 kilometer pro stunde schnell sein soll und in 1,9 sekunden von 0 auf 100
beschleunigen soll
Maske kann von seinen problemen ablenken aber in aus reihen hat er jetzt geliefert und hat gezeigt dass er auch super ehrgeizige
zeitpläne einhalten kann
Am ersten september wurde der vertrag für die batterie farm
Unterzeichnet und jetzt ist es soweit schon nach knapp 90 tagen und das war auch bitter nötig denn jetzt fängt in australien die heiße jahreszeit
An der sommer auf der südhalbkugel ist ja genau dann wenn bei uns winter ist und da werden die
klimaanlagen eingeschaltet und ordentlich stromverbrauch für die batterien fahren in australien ist deshalb eine riesen wette eingegangen
Erwartete die farm in 100 tagen zu bauen dabei wird sie eine kapazität von 100 megawatt haben sie ist in der lage
30.000 häuser mit strom
Zu versorgen was ist sie damit dreimal stärker als jede bisher auf der welt gebaute batterie farm in kalifornien hatte tesla bereits
eine fast batterien anfang 2017 fertiggestellt damals brauchte tesla
90 tage für 20 megawatt für den klimawandel sind das auf jeden fall gute nachrichten und auch für deutschland sind solche batterien fahren ja extrem
Interessant wenn wir komplett aus der kohleverstromung
Aussteigen wollen dann sind sie nötig zu all diesen themen halte ich euch natürlich hier auf dem laufenden wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollten dann
sollten
aber aufs auge und vor allem gibt mir einen
Auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
dafür draufklicken mit tempo 200 unterirdisch durch die stadt darin routiniert maske mal eben den innerstädtischen verkehr
Das ist wirklich ziemlich irre also bis dann
bleibt dran